[music]
>> The reason I
quoted this ayah after the ummah by
is because
naturally I'm
very nervous person.
And at times I tend to stutter.
And this is a dua I'm making to Allah.
And through this
I'm hoping that he'll make my
communication reach your hearts.
My name is Imran.
And
I come from very humble beginnings.
I was born in Bangalore and I had my
education in Vellore,
Tamil Nadu.
And most of them were Christian schools.
So
a lot about Christianity I got I got to
learn
while I was a little child.
And even
uh the
televisions back in those days would
only talk about either Mahabharata or
the Jesus shows.
Yeah, so
I had fair idea about Christianity,
very little about Islam.
It is when I started doing my higher
secondary, which was in Government
Muslim Higher Secondary School,
that my Muslim friends
actually showed me what Islam was.
And
I got more and more attracted to it. But
my passion towards Dawah was not not yet
established.
It was very recently that one of my
customers,
when I was working in call center. By
the way, I was a call center employee a
little before joining IRF.
And it was the customers who brought it
to my attention that nearly 6 months 7
months ago, there was an incident in
Texas,
which
made an uprise
about the paintings of uh Prophet
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
And well, it was shocking for me.
And
I was expecting a stronger reaction from
Muslims. When I shared about this, the
the reaction from Muslims was surprising
for me that they they were quite calm.
And on the other hand, the uh
Christians, their reaction was pretty
natural, of course.
So
I saw a lot of people trying to defend
Islam. They didn't know they didn't have
the knowledge.
People started I mean, what little
knowledge I had was also not there, but
they were still emotionally trying to
defend. So that's when I started doing
more research.
And I uh
stum- I mean, I I
stumbled across a lot of good da'ees
like uh Dr. Zakir Naik
and uh Nouman Ali Khan and uh Dr.
Shabbir Ally,
you know,
Husain Yee
and and few more including
Ahmed Deedat Sheikh.
Uh so I I Whatever I have learned is is
only through uh
these great da'ees. If it weren't for
these guys,
I wouldn't be standing here.
Alhamdulillah.
And uh
Dr. Dr. Zakir Naik
was one of the first two da'ees I ever
knew. He was in Bangalore
uh about 10 years little over 10 years
ago at the uh
the palace ground with
Yusuf Estes.
So
I was back then surprised to see a
Muslim talking about other religious
scriptures.
I mean, it was understandable to see
Yusuf Estes talking about Islam because
he embraced it, but the way Dr. Zakir
presented
a different view from anyone would have
seen back then. His style hasn't changed
till today, as
as you can see.
He pretty much goes with the same
openings and uh of course, the Quranic
ayahs don't change, but his style
remains the same. So alhamdulillah, we
we always there is always a learning to
learn from him. And
I I had already begun
the idea to do Dawah
on social media.
And
I'm also a graphic designer.
I've done my course, but I haven't been
professionally practicing it because it
was only a hobby.
So I went ahead and started working on
social media doing whatever little I can
and joined IOU, Islamic Online
University, which is Dr.
Bilal Philips' University.
And and learned a little bit more.
So um
yeah, and then there was a time when I
wanted to do Dawah, so I I do I I
uh got I I actually requested IOU
to see if I can join their social media
team
for Dawah.
Around that time I I I
I saw fortunately that there was an
opportunity to work
with IRF as a da'ee
through this training program. So I went
ahead and applied. Alhamdulillah for
what happened. I'm grateful to Allah.
With this I would like to end my speech.
Wa akhir Dawah alhamdulillah hi rabbil
alamin.
Alhamdulillah hi rabbil alamin.
Wa usalli wa usallim ala ashrafil ambiya
wal mursalin nabiyina wa habibina wa
qudwatina wa imamina alaihi wa ala alihi
afdalus salati wa atamut taslimi am ma
ba'd.
All praises indeed due to Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala, the one and all. Complete
blessings and salutations upon Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
Firstly, I would like to start off with
my name.
I am Ahmed Omar Muhammad Yusuf.
And I was born in Kandy, which is the
hill capital of Sri Lanka.
And right now, alhamdulillah, I've moved
on to Colombo, which is the capital city
of Sri Lanka, and I've gained my
education and we are living there,
alhamdulillah.
So as far as my family background is
concerned,
I come from a very knowledgeable family.
One thing Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala can
give a family,
it is a great bounty that Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala can give a family is a good
lineage.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala blessed me with
that.
My family is such
I hail from a family as such that three
generations above me are scholars,
alhamdulillah.
And now
by the grace of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
that I've also turned up a scholar
last year, alhamdulillah.
I gained my as far as my education is
concerned,
I gained my bachelor in Islamic science
and I've completed that successfully and
I'm hoping to go more and study about
Islam and become an effective da'ee,
inshallah Ta'ala.
That is my hope and that is my dream as
well.
Well, I never thought that I would be a
part of such a program that would create
effective da'ees, inshallah Ta'ala.
As far as my
activities are concerned, Dawah
activities, I'm a part of three things
in Colombo.
Number one,
it is an organization which is
uh well versed
in activities of Dawah in social media.
That is called I have a network called
WTT Network.
What I try to say from that is the
message that I give from that is we try
to walk what ever we talk.
So walk the talk network. I used to make
episodes online every week to benefit
the people for the past 2 years,
alhamdulillah.
So that is happening. Meanwhile,
I am engaged with a program or a
charitable trust that my father is a
part of.
A charitable trust which engages which
is which creates possibilities to give
Dawah to people through social service.
We've engaged in many activities of
social service and charitable activities
which will give them an introduction of
Islam, which will give them an
introduction of how Islam gives
specialty and importance to hospitality.
My beloved brothers and elders in Islam,
that's number two.
And number three, I'm involved in a
prominent institution in Colombo, which
is also run by my father, which is known
as Fath Academy.
Academy of success. So in that academy,
we give Islamic education plus the
secondary education, the school,
whatever they teach, they they also
teach that in the school, higher
secondary school, plus the Islamic
studies which goes right till the higher
secondary school, alhamdulillah. I'm a
part of all these three things. That is
a part of my Dawah. And I wish that I
want to become one effective and
full-time da'ee, inshallah Ta'ala. I
have three objectives from this
particular program that I wish to get
inshallah to Allah. Number one,
I want this training program to be to
make me transform but not only gain
information.
It should give It should be a
transformation for all of us, not an
information-based thing.
Number two, it must make us feel
the duties that we have, not to claim
our rights.
And number three, we should understand
and we should make feel ourself
that we become people who serve the
society,
not people who survive with what we
learn.
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala grant us
the opportunity to become effective
da'is and may he give us the opportunity
to become people whom Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala accept us accepted us. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala unite us in the
gardens of paradise, just as he united
us in this beautiful Mumbai. Wa akhiru
da'wana alhamdulillah rabbil alameen.
Alhamdulillah. Before we have the short
break,
I would just like to ask I know that
many of you have been on the stage
before.
Who has come
for the first time on the stage in his
life? Raise your hand.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four. Five.
Six.
Can you raise your hand a bit higher?
Who has come on the stage the first
time? One, two, three, four, five, six.
Masha Allah. So, how's the experience?
Anyone want to give us comments?
How's the experience?
Sorry?
Terrifying.
So, I'm a terrorist.
And all the others, maybe 13 of you have
come on the stage before.
How many have come
on such a stage Such a stage means
there's a different stage
as compared to other stages. Stages are
of various types.
Some are professional, some are
non-professional.
How many have come before
on such a stage
which is mainly created
to go on a satellite only?
One, two, three, four.
Four.
Masha Allah.
These two are from school, one has been
to my show before, and brother
Kamaruddin, alhamdulillah.
Masha Allah.
Now, you're supposed to have the
objectives of the training program,
which we shall have after the lunch
break. We are running
approximately 45 minutes
behind schedule.
So, we'll have the break
for the Zuhr salah
and
we will not shorten the lunch break.
We'll keep it 1 hour. I don't want to
shorten the break. We'll inshallah
resume at 2:30, inshallah. 15 minutes
for the Zuhr salah,
1 hour for the lunch break.
Inshallah, 2:30 we'll come back and we
may extend maybe a session after Maghrib
or we'll try and shorten the session,
inshallah. So, inshallah, we'll meet
sharp
at
2:30, inshallah, in the same auditorium.
Wa akhiru da'wana alhamdulillah rabbil
alameen.
>> [music]
[singing]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [chanting]
[music]